we're enix have decided to get in on the
e3 party why not why doesn't everybody
just evolve kondu who knows there's not
enough conferences 83 is what my main
point is you can catch the square Enix
show on Tuesday jun 16 10 a.m. pacific
brightener yes dinner time if you're in
the UK and ireland I'm very happy to be
joined by Sri myself what's going on ed
tribes here as well down hands hey doing
good Oh lousy here yep well is he all
the time bringing all the Tim times we'd
appreciate it first of all squeenix
actually have a bunch of really
interesting games talk about let's talk
about a game that I know you're a
massive fan of de deus ex yeah we're
going to see mankind divided yeah this
is literally my favorite game series and
Zoe and I were replaying a human
Revolution yesterday and there was a
security camera and she was like do you
think i can take it out by throwing this
fire extinguisher at it and I'm like I
don't know maybe so she did and I wow
really yeah and the great thing about
that game exactly like that to me is
days x in a nutshell ya know like okay
we're going to have more augmentations
and there's new store in your conspiracy
but all I really want from it is like
more creative ways to solve more complex
problems it's interesting that they
manage to like in many ways it's so
different to the first two games but
that's core of like a merging gameplay
actually I did run through yeah and
maybe the only criticism I could think
of that of the last game human
Revolution was all the bus bites though
the ossified stuff was anything you'd
like them to do differently this time I
mean they fix them to a certain degree
in the director's cut which I play
through as well but they could still be
better you know it was they just needed
to be normal NPCs rather than like
special characters with a million health
never say that then we're gonna add the
ability to ghost the whole game this
time okay yeah that sounds good so just
like sleep by everything yeah cool let's
just don't write at all hey sexy walking
some story soon no it is making possible
an exclusive for the xbox one or rather
a day timed exclusive for the Xbox one
rise of the Tomb Raider sequel to a
really fantastic action game yeah which
came out a couple years ago edge you
excited for this bad boy I
and this is like one of the games that
is like making me kind of want to get an
xbox and I'm personally over this phone
no I really love to meta you know I had
a bit of trouble getting into it but it
was it really so take a while another
solid game serene fan of the the reboot
of tomato musical I can't wait to be
honest like this is going to sound
really strange but I love seeing Laura
get hurt well they made the game for you
yeah I say that because like it's like
you know like she's a survivor you know
it's not like all just staying pretty
ela everything falls into place exactly
where you want it to so you know the
fact that she gets hurt and she gets a
rugged and run down a lot too much
violence porn for you know it's it's
weird because there was a surprising
backlash to some of the obviously there
was one incident incident where she's
assaulted but there was a surprising
backlash to just the like visceral
nature of the violence and I came like
the night the wind I should shop soon
like you know some of those stuff that
happens to her is completely like whoa I
did not think I really thinking the same
thing about like the PlayStation 1
original know when you jump Holly I'm
you crumpled up yeah buddy having a
deathly screen yeah yeah well I think
yeah yeah I mean all I wanted this one
is the the not have the puzzle sections
be completely optional yeah you know if
like the actual tomb raiding yes
surprisingly the tomb raiding was a sort
of psych West yep stumble into it looks
like from what we've seen the trailer
that actually could be the the focus
that she's on her own in these
environments which would be very
evocative of the first game yeah it's
doing a very uncharted thing you know
jungle first snow second there's a world
and the underwater bubble game at the
fourth game in Final Fantasy 15
apparently we're not going to see any
gameplay yeah when they just released
the update to the Gemma's it's not the
weirdest day ever so strange like I
don't know what that means like I
interviewed the director recently and
like he was saying like the demo isn't
indicative of house completes the game
is and my people that he was like oh
wait sixty percent done and it's like
what are you saying is completely
backtracking all that and they had that
form where they put out and they got
feedback on the demo as well and says
actually we're going to make quite a lot
of this yeah a bit disappointing we're
not gonna see it well I don't know I
don't know you can play at home is a
pretty nice thing
I'm coming in if all III games got demos
during you through those be pretty good
like the ground zeroes of final fantasy
version and testing it with and being
like all right we'll do this man yeah
and what I'd like to see is a little
small playable version of Jaws Cause 3
and that people looking forward to this
one I remember the multiplayer mod that
came out for just cause 2 made some
waves yeah I said they are going to be
doing some multiplayer and 3 i'm not
sure if it'll be that big on launch but
uh yeah any takers for this one
excitement about just goes through
absolutely i want to grab whoever e-wrap
link on video yep tethering things two
things and then making the crash into
each other just make would like physics
simulator this is goat simulator this is
basically came intimately except every
time i see this it looks like like a
third person tropico it's like they
should be in the same yeah i mean just
cause 2 is already turned out to 11 so
this is what 12 Just Cause 3 is the sim
copter to go Sin City and it's been a
while actually just goes to commit in
2010 so yeah yeah look as long as I keep
this one as moddable as just cause 2 yes
yeah yeah probably gonna be a big seller
on earthly yeah this trailer is just a
bunch of explosions I don't think
they're hopeful it is as well we should
have a counter place like taking off all
these yeah I've noticed a lot of the the
new games the crop is a brightener you
know like is everything's really bright
this yeah scenes yes God that's like a
baller who knew and I'm not a massive
fan I've never really played these games
so I can't really speak to it but a
kingdom hearts looks like we're probably
gonna have to see something along the
lines of it oh we have to we us so
overdue like it's been so long since
we've had a number kingdom hearts title
and I think like the fans are rabid as
they need a slash fig that every and
brainy making and I'll pregnancy LA and
the Alexa told us it's so funny to think
about square enix owning like properties
like Tomb Raider and deus ex and another
kind of weird one that I often have to
like remind myself oh yeah they own
hitman have peculiar and I'm a massive I
think we're big pc game with vesa game
finds the him and series has had the
some absolute incredible peaks and some
you know valleys that weren't so hot
yeah
would you like to see in a new hitman
game well you know the developers have
been really open about the feedback from
hitman absolution and then being like
all right we know what was wrong with it
we're going back to open levels where
you just actually plan an assassination
rather than get funneled down this weird
story which nobody really liked not that
kind of deus ex style some
experimentation yes everything can work
with everything that's got a used to be
over soon as in like comp about like
levels that were separate from you know
like Deus Ex where there were open
contained levels if you were with
different ways of completing it felt
like a location that you were like a
logical location and they're like maybe
three of those in absolution and they
were the best parts but it was still
quite constricted I've never understood
the fascination of the lore with hitman
because like like Tobias Reaper like
when they got into the end of the first
game and all that yeah cloned stuff but
like there's been two completes me I've
seen the first 14 separate feelin all
the fun yeah I saw two it's it's is
unimpressive it's not it's just weird
it's a and then the new warming that
happened in that movie yeah I chose to
ignore it in the new one as well like
they just keep balding famous actors
hahahahaha make sure he's saying yes ask
where I decided to do their own press
conference as it turns out there's a
bunch of em interesting games gap I'm
going to go one by one before we finish
is really what are you most looking
forward to out of what square could
possibly be showing off Kingdom Hearts 3
and it also because I'm really excited
because you know dizzy now and the Star
Wars meant mom franchises so you know
that opens a whole world of
possibilities that I want to see them
work with so who knows and what are you
gonna D figurine compatibility no no I'm
not excited a sex as well likely excite
a bit you know that's dancing so I'm
looking forward to when you hit man if
it is announced mmm c5 ma'am they don't
a lot of stuff yeah just days excess
yeah I'm actually really excited for
deus ex because of your excitement
fidessa and i never really pays
infectious I never gives the last one a
proper swing actually so I kind of feel
like I need to go bring back the elbow
blades yeah yeah a little go let's get
some Jason companies this time get some
treats are back in this bar boy square
enix is wonderful little presentation we
actually don't need no
what sort of form it will take what
it'll be licensed massive big conference
will be sort of a smaller thing it's on
tuesday jun 16 to 10 am frightened early
pacific if you're watching in the US on
the west coast and it's on at 6pm dinner
time between UK and ireland we would
love you to join us on gamespot com to
watch it live